but see this is another thing we're not
talking about in our own District a guy
that owns a bodega was defending his
Bodega and ended up stabbing somebody to
death that was getting robbed and he had
a 500 000 Bond and they loaded to 250
000 so people in New York you can rub
feces on somebody and get out of jail
within 24 hours but if you defend your
Bodega you're going to get charged with
manslaughter and you're not even going
to be able to get out of jail so the
hypocrisy in her own District it's
literally rotting like the Big Apple
it's the rotting apple right now and
she's all worried about me saying big
booty latina so her priorities are
absolutely Screwed Up the documentary is
called knock down the house knock down
the house it's from 2019. I I think
she's I think the points about her not
feeling safe are interesting because one
I I'm hoping that like when she was
talking about one six she was like
clapping her hands clapping her hands
and and she looked like tariff like just
completely nervous wreck I imagine
someone in capital would feel like that
these days with this heightened sense of
security with the economy you know
inflation and things like that and I
want to help
um but also it's not it's not cool to
tell people to go make politicians
uncomfortable I mean maybe
yeah that's a very vague thing to tell I
don't I don't know I don't know I think
AOC might be right but she's just a
hypocrite and I want to say this I
actually the only reason I disagree with
you is because this is part of the
left's narrative they have to be a
victim victimhood is their favorite
thing because if you play the victim
then they're not responsible for your
actions and it's like oh well if you're
poor you can steal you know so it's kind
of their victimhood mentality and AOC
she plays a victim better than anybody
in congress yet she's super successful
she's really young she's been afforded
every opportunity possible in life but
she can if she if you give her an inch
she's going to take a mile of victimhood
but this is why she's so so popular
among the millennial left she
exemplifies them given every opportunity
a bit privileged and then complaining
about it living one of the most
comfortable and comfortable lives in the
world and complaining she talks a lot
about how she came from humble
beginnings she used to be a waitress and
blah blah blah bartender you know yeah
but then ask ask ask why there are
people who are traveling thousands of
miles crawling through desert to come
here to work in the you know industrial
setting or in in a chicken factory and
she was a waitress living in you know
New York or whatever in Manhattan in
many square one of the nicest
neighborhoods in New York but at that
famous Union Square Restaurant right
yeah and so she probably did really well
because bartenders actually do pretty
good but it's funny because you make a
point and we talk about the Border over
108 000 drug overdose deaths this year
the the issue that we're having with
fentanyl people are literally dying
young kids opioid epidemic is one of the
worst problems that we're facing in
politicians and this is the problem that
I have with the conservative side forget
about the 80 billion dollars we're given
to Ukraine forget about Dan Crenshaw
voting for service members that aren't
vaccinated to get kicked out of the
military it doesn't matter if you have
an r or D next to your name I want them
to have an a extra name for America and
that's the problem is that we have all
of these politicians that are run by
multinational corporations businesses
are deciding really what's happening in
the world so it doesn't matter if you're
right or left because they do not care
about the border between Texas and
Mexico yet they're giving 80 billion
dollars to defend the border between
Russia and Ukraine and for me that
mostly makes me sick because listen I
love the gay community I love the trans
Community but if you're in the Ukraine
you cannot gay marriage is illegal if
you're transgender in the Ukraine and
you try to go to Poland they give you a
gun and they say get back on the front
line so the country that we're defending
the most with a huge majority of our
money does not even have the same
culture that we have here in America and
during pride month no less they were
giving all this money I saw and I went
to the New York City Pride and I saw
more Ukrainian Flags than I saw rainbow
well I saw more rainbow Flags but I'm
just saying I saw a lot of ukrainians in
all seriousness though there could have
been that quid pro quo there could have
been Joe Biden saying you guys got to
ease up on the lgbtq you stuff we're
going to fund you but let's Tim this is
what makes me so mad I don't care all
day long Hunter Biden can smoke crack
all day long no serious I'm dead serious
as a matter of fact I think that makes
him endearing everybody knows somebody
that's a drug addict what we don't talk
about we don't talk about his business
dealings in China we don't talk about
the quid pro quid pro quo Joe talking
about giving a billion dollars making
sure they had the right people in power
in the Ukraine and now we're fighting a
proxy war we're fighting a war by proxy
killing young people over what over
decisions made by a crackhead president
by the president's crackhead son that it
gets that gets no media attention but
they're going to give you the
prostitutes all day long they're going
to give you the crack pipe all day long
like you should talk about the quid pro
quo stuff like I don't shut up about it
no but but what I'm saying is your
frustration about hey I'm so mad that
you know he's the big booty uh Latina is
a head story because the real story is
that January 6 the Capitol Police let
people in and that's obvious because
people couldn't get in they didn't have
a key to get into the door but it's the
same thing the crazy thing is there's
that video going viral right now where
the window was smashed out they still
can't get in because it's mag locked and
then these guys look up at someone and
point and then someone releases the
maglock and that could have been an
insurrectionist whatever you want to
call them it may be someone broken found
the maglock release and they said press
it or maybe it was a cop because we did
see other cops open the door directly we
saw other cops taking selfies so I'm
with AOC on that one I want the
investigation too no thousand percent we
want the investigation obviously she
thinks the outcome will be different
from what the right thinks it will be
but I don't think that's relevant I
think the question is what happened and
we look at January 6 you know obviously
there's some people one of my very good
friends Luke Coffey you know he has a
GoFundMe he's actually being charged
with assaulting a police officer he's
actually kind of well known he's the
crutch guy and he held a crutch he found
a crutch on the ground and did he kind
of you know put it against her right
Shields and now he's being charged with
assaulting a cop and let me tell you
something the guy's a 37 year old young
nice kid that you know felt you know
that there was an injustice even though
it was the 37 year old young kid I'm
just saying he's a young middle-aged man
middle-aged man but I'm just saying he's
not he's not built for excuse me he's
not built for federal prison is my point
being I think he would be young for
prison but it was the most Fair election
the best election ever Joe Biden got 81
million votes I just want to put that on
record my point being
there is people there that loved our
country very much and now they're being
labeled as a domestic terrorist they're
saying it's worse than 9 11. and for me
I look back at our government's track
record the same people that said we had
weapons of mass destruction which we
didn't are the same people that saying
American citizens that love our country
the most are terrorists so the
government's going to lie to you to
create a narrative that's not true I'll
tell you what I think I think the people
that write it I think the people that
were fighting with cops even pushing on
the cops that's bad and there's got to
be uh some accountability there that's
fair but
um I think that when Trump gets in
office in 2024 well in 2025 blanket
pardon across the board oh hey [ __ ] but
do you think Trump will beat DeSantis I
don't know I don't know but I'm saying
like I'm not saying that will happen I'm
just saying if Trump order since it gets
in I think without condemning uh well
actually no with a little condemnation
but with recognizing the threat this
country faces through the massive divide
I think you've got to get these people
out yeah um you've talked about it
before which is rebellious Rebellion
yeah John Hancock pardoned a bunch of
the farmers that had rebelled because
they were being overtaxed they didn't
have the money they were just back from
the revolution Soldiers with their
fortunes depleted and then they were
getting imprisoned because they didn't
have the money still that they didn't
have and they just surrounded the
courthouse refused to let the people the
judges act and they there was jail
sentences and stuff and then Hancock
came and was like no no we're forming a
union you're pardoned everyone's
pardoned well let's talk about let's
talk about Trump because everybody loves
Trump and I love the Trump that calls
Little Marco Rubio or you know I love
the Trump what's he gonna say about
DeSantis I think I think Hancock didn't
pardon he pardoned everyone except for
like three people or two people but my
point being is listen Trump I think had
11 days in office where he could have
pardoned some people you look at Trump
with Julian Assange who the Wikileaks
basically gave him the 2016 election yet
he doesn't get a pardon you know uh
Kodak Black gets one I'm not saying that
Kodak Black you know good rapper not
saying you shouldn't get one but I think
Trump has a serious you know priority
issue I I just I just
I gotta point this out never in my life
growing up as like in the 2000s into
Occupy Wall Street and after for several
years after did I think that at one
point in my life I would be sitting
across the table from a conservative I
would say yes yeah well I'm kind of down
the middle but yeah suit wearing Guy
arguing that the Republican president
should have pardoned Julian Assange
because 10 years ago the left loved
Assange and now they leave him hanging
out to dry they they leave him to rot
Tim you made your bones oh excuse me
well you say what you're going to say I
was going to say Trump is the reason
they're trying to uh extradite Julian
Assange too I think Trump wanted Julian
Assange because Julian knows things
about the DNC and Trump wanted that and
so now he's being handed off to Joe
Biden which is extremely dangerous but
anyway well let's talk about occupy
because I know that was you know a huge
thing for you those people were very
anti-establishment then those people
were anti-banks now these people love
Pfizer they love Banks they love
Halliburton so it just shows you these
people are under what I call Mass
formation hypnosis they don't even know
whose side to be on I agree and this
wasn't that long ago like you said in
2008 when we had the financial crash
people were out there protesting for
what I agree is I'm anti-establishment
I'm not right or left I just don't like
the establishment I think that the
system is just terrible and the people
in power once they get in power I talk
about the multinational corporations all
they care about is their political
action committee they care about the
money that they're getting donated it's
like you look at Apple you know Apple
freaking in in China at their Foxconn
factories instead of paying their
employees more they have suicide Nets
because so many employees are jumping
off the roof but instead of paying them
a little more they make stronger Nets
they make bigger Nets so we have a
priority issue because it's the
globalization of America and that's why
I'm an American first guy because I care
about America I want to actually put
America in the Forefront but if you say
you're a nationalist or if you have an
American flag in your yard that's a hate
symbol your right wing now yeah exactly
conservative and I'm altered I'm
considered alt right because I love
America and that's not how it should be
but they create a narrative that America
is bad bad yet nearly a hundred thousand
people even more than that illegally
cross into our country every month so go
figure if it's such a racist Place why
why does everyone want to immigrate here
man you you hit the nail on the head uh
right there I completely agree
um I never really cared all that much
for the left the right you know or that
idea is it was always just like the
machine is broken it is unjust it is
corrupt it is manipulative and so that
is for me especially it starts with the
media because the media is lying to
people and they just go along with it so
that is that's really what got me here
early on in my career I wasn't talking
that much about Democrats Republicans it
was the media in their lives well as
time goes on you start to realize
they're lying to benefit the uniparty
which morphed into the Democrats when
Trump took over and then you get a
narrative the Democratic party is the
party of the establishment wealthy
Elites the media props them up the
Lincoln project and the neocons joined
the Democrats after Trump took over half
the Republican party is extremely bad
the other third is really bad is a small
handful of them that are okay for me I'm
like Thomas Massey's cool Rand Paul I
like Carter Taylor green is great and
the rest of them there's a few others
that are that are doing a decently good
job but the machine itself is dominated
by the uni party and it's just corrupt I
don't care about how many how much taxes
you want to take that's that's ancillary
it's after the fact we can have a
conversation about that for the time
being it's corrupt people lying cheating
and stealing and destroying the country
I wonder if it's the media is
manipulating the politicians I'm sure
it's happening on some level or if
they're all colluding or if the
politicians are making the media act
that way but I think like like
Alexandria Cortez she didn't ever
mention I've never heard her mention the
one six cops letting people in on one
six like I've never heard her mention
that until a couple days ago and it's
been two years of people in solitary did
she not hear about it through are they
that insulated like that it's hard to
think that people could be so insulated
that they don't see what I see but we're
I've spent a lot of my time looking at a
lot of things from the outside I think
when you're in that DC environment you
may they may actually be very intense
nationally insulated no Ian I deserve
all the credit I broke her you know I
broke her I created an emotional she
thinks that getting called a big booty
latina is the same gravity as one six a
hundred percent she thinks the cops you
know were basically you know they since
they didn't arrest me which they did
they did she complained five times she
said that in her own tweet and the cops
did come and they id'd me I gave my ID I
said am I under arrest am I being
detained they said no and I was able to
walk away and her watching me walk away
I know made her so mad that she's like I
hate these Capital police oh my God they
let the writers in so um
but what was interesting is that she she
then she must have known about it for a
while oh come on Ian everybody knows
about this and listen she's the same
person that said she was afraid of her
life yet she was a mile away and at the
same time even if every single rioter
went in did they really think that they
were going to be able to you know even
do any sort of legislation come on she
so this is a narrative that for some
reason has even been difficult to uh
permeate the right when AOC said she was
scared when they came and knocked on her
door she wasn't just not in the capital
she fabricated the story outright well
politician lied what this is a tough one
I don't claimed to be in one of the
bathrooms hiding in her office let me
let me break this down for you because I
will tell the story every chance I get
AOC did an Instagram video it's about 45
minutes long where she's sad she's in
her office and she hears a knock knock
and she got scared thinking it's them
they've gotten here what do I do and
they said go hide in the bathroom and I
did and the door opens and it's a police
officer going or it's a man going where
is she
where is she and she's like I she said
she thought she was gonna die turns out
as a police officer evacuating her what
she doesn't tell you although she kind
of does is that she's in there pooping
no is that that happened I believe one
full hour before the barricades were
breached at the front of the building
meaning no one knew anyone was going to
get into the capital
you know right well AOC claimed she
thought they had made it to her her off
her office how does that make sense
nobody was in the building nobody knew
they were running in the building and if
AOC knew they were going to breach the
building why didn't she report it weird
questions there right the media tried
defending her saying yes she wasn't in
the capital she was in her office but
there are tunnels that connect the
capital to her office that explains it I
had a guy from The Huffington Post tell
me that I was wrong when I tweeted her
story didn't make sense and he DMS me
and then I put the timeline and he
responds in a private DM going like oh
oh you're right she when she claimed
that she thought they got to her office
and she was gonna die no one had even
attempted to breach the Capitol building
she made the story up it was like a full
hour before the barricades even moved
something like that and then they made
their way to the front of the capital
but AOC had no idea was going to happen
she fabricated the story after the fact
and people bought it believed it they
still do this I've been thinking lately
no matter how emotional I am about
something no matter how strongly I feel
about something it doesn't make it more
or less right like
so getting crying saying it's real
doesn't make it more or less
manipulation yeah you have to be
emotional and and I don't want to get
too conspiratorial but it kind of sounds
like you remember how Larry Silverstein
during 9 11 you know he's usually has
breakfast there and he happened to be
having a uh a little doctor's
appointment for his skin I'm just saying
you know it's not a surprise that these
people probably do have prior knowledge
of stuff that's going to happen and we
talk about Ray Epps because I know you
want to expose that but literally he's
on camera saying we need to have an
Insurrection we need to go inside yet
you look at the mainstream media New
York Times Adam kinzinger if they're
running cover for him they are running
cover then you know what the truth is
you know that he's involved in they're
protecting him but but let me say this
real quick because we know about the
Mockingbird media we know the government
admits that they have literally
intelligence and every radio television
film every form of media that we have so
it would be impossible
for him to be this protected by the
media if he wasn't in on it thanks for
checking out this clip from timcast IRL
come hang out live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm Eastern Time Super Chat will
even answer some of your questions if
you want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up Monday
through Thursday at 11 PM they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time